(Musik)
Bonjour et bienvenue à La Seine Musicale. Hallo und wilkommen in der Seine Musicale
Die wunderschöne Musik, die ihr gerade hört, stammt vom renommierten Insula Orchester und ich hatte die Möglichkeit mir
Im nagelneuen Konzertsaal in Boulogne-Billancourt in der Nähe von Paris ein klassisches Konzert anzuhören.
Aber, damit nicht genug ich konnte mir auch, quasi als Vergleich, dieselbe Oper in der in Hamburger Elbphilharmonie
anhören, denn was viele nicht wissen: Die Konzertsäle wurden nicht nur beide 2017 eröffnet, sondern sind auch vom selben Akustiker entworfen worden.
Yasuhisa Toyota
Mit dabei war der französische YouTuber Guilleaume der auf seinem Kanal über klassische Musik redet und ich als Doktor Whatson
war vor allem da, um einiges über Akustik zu lernen.
(Musik)
Willkommen in Hamburg
Ja, willkommen in der Elbphilharmonie. Wir sind jetzt gerade auf der längsten, gebogenen Rolltreppe der Welt und fahren nach oben in den großen Konzertsaal der Elbphilharmonie.
(Musik)
Was heute nach vielen Mehrkosten und verschobenen Eröffnungen
endlich wunderschön über Hamburg thront, basiert auf einem alten Lagergebäude an der Elbe, das eigentlich schon sein Zenit überschritten hatte.
"Es gab sehr konkrete Überlegungen daraus einen großen
Büroturm zu machen und es gab einen Wettbewerb der schon entschieden war, wie das aussehen sollte und es gab ein
Ehepaar und zwar Alexander Gerard und Diana Marco die sagten: "Nein
Das muss was für die Musik sein. Das muss ein Konzerthaus werden. Das kann doch ein Konzerthaus werden, oder?"
Es gibt zwei Botschaften die diese Elbphilharmonie mit auf den Weg bekommen hat und das eine ist: Sie sollte eines der zehn besten Konzerthäuser
der Welt sein und das Andere ist, dass sie ein Haus für alles sein soll. Man kann hochfahren und sich die Stadt von oben angucken
und wir haben eine ganz wesentliche Aufgabe darin
eine Musikvermittlung zu betreiben und das ist Paris eigentlich ein bisschen unser Vorbild. Es gibt also viele Schulkonzerte, Kinderkonzerte
ein Publikumsfest, ein Familienorchester.
Beim Gestalten
des großen Konzertsaals der Elbphilharmonie stand der Klang immer an erster Stelle
Von der Wand mit ihren unzähligen Ecken, Kanten und Krümmungen über die speziell gepolsterte Sitze bis zum großen Pilz, der von der Decke hängt.
Alles hat einen enormen Einfluss auf die Akustik des Raumes.
In diesen Modellen kann zum Beispiel berechnet werden, wie gut die Stühle auf Schallwellen reagieren. In einem ausverkauften Saal
absorbieren die Zuschauer mit ihren Körpern und der Kleidung eine menge Schallwellen.
Wenn jemand zusieht, möchte das Orchester aber natürlich trotzdem mit der gleichen Akustik proben. Die Stühle sind also extra
so designt, dass sie mehr Schall absorbieren, wenn niemand auf ihnen sitzt.
Und in den Wänden verbirgt sich noch ein verblüffendes Geheimnis. Jede einzelne Wölbung und jedes Loch im Saal wurde von einem Algorithmus entworfen.
Parametrisches Design nennt sich dieser Prozess. Ein Computer verändert
Variablen zum Beispiel die Tiefe der eine Million Zellen in den Wänden so lange bis das bestmögliche Endergebnis erzielt wurde.
In diesem Fall eine möglichst ausgewogene Akustik. Das Ergebnis sind 10.000
individuelle Platten, die genau aufeinander abgestimmt sind.
Der Pilz an der Decke hat wiederum eine andere Funktion.
Er sorgt dafür, dass die Schallwellen des Orchesters direkt unter ihm nicht sofort in der Decke verschwinden.
Stattdessen reflektiert er sie vor allem in die oberen Ränge. Daher kommt auch der Name:
Reflektor
(Musik)
Was wir auf jeden Fall vermeiden wollen, ist, dass die Schallwellen direkt reflektiert werden. Deswegen wurde diese Struktur hier gebaut.
Das sind Wellen aus Holz,
die den Schall an verschiedenen Auftrittspunkten in andere Richtungen reflektieren.
Das heißt wenn der Schall hier auftritt, wird er in diese Richtung reflektiert und wenn er hier auftritt, wird er dann  in diese Richtung reflektiert.
Und durch das ganze Muster auf der gesamten Wand wird der Schall hier wunderbar diffus
im Raum verteilt und das gibt dieses einzigartige Klangverhältnis und dieses wunderbare Schallverhältnis.
(Musik)
Das bedeutet eine längere Nachhallzeit klingt voller,
bombastischer. Eine kürzere Nachhallzeit ist präziser und erlaubt es besser einzelne Instrumente zu hören.
Dafür werden aber auch Fehler schneller deutlich
und das war auch die Kritik an der Elbphilharmonie, die eine kurze Nachhallzeit von nur 2,2 Sekunden hat. Man hört alles direkt und linear.
Nichts mischt sich. Die Seine Musicale dagegen vergibt mehr und vermengt die vielen Instrumente des Orchesters zu einem Ganzen.
Jemand der sich besonders gut mit Klängen auskennt, ist Laurance Equilbey die Dirigentin des in Suhl Orchesters. Zu einer guten Akustik
gehören für sie viele Elemente.
(Musik)
Im Gegensatz zu anderen Hallen ist der Reflektor, also der Pilz, in der Elbphilharmonie nicht höhenverstellbar.
Stattdessen kann man die Balance zwischen den Instrumentengruppen anpassen, indem man einzelne
Bühnenelemente anhebt. Auf diese Weise kann man zum Beispiel nur die Akustik der Streicher verändern ohne den Rest des Orchesters zu beeinflussen.
Was viele nicht wissen. Bei einem Konzertsaal ist nicht nur wichtig, was das Publikum hört,
sondern auch was die Musiker hören. Wer sein eigenes Instrument
im Klangkarussell des Orchesters nicht richtig heraushören kann, spielt womöglich zu laut oder nicht im richtigen Tempo.
Eine gute Konzerthalle zeichnet sich also immer auch dadurch aus, dass die Musiker das Gleiche wie das Publikum hören.
Der Trichter über dem großen Pilz sorgt genau dafür. Er absorbiert den überflüssigen Schall, der sonst die Musiker stören würde.
(Musik)
Festzustellen bleibt, dass wir es hier mit zwei akustischen und architektonischen Meisterwerken zu tun haben.
Am Ende des Tages muss jeder selbst entscheiden, ob
er es eher kühl und brillant mag, wie in Hamburg, oder warm und klangvoll, wie in der Seine Musicale.
Ich genieße jetzt noch die letzten Klänge von Haydn`s Schöpfung und bedanke mich noch einmal
Recht herzlich beim in Suhl Orchester für die Einladung in zwei sehr spannende Konzertsäle. Merci beaucoup.
Wie immer bleibt neugierig, euer Cedric.
(Musik)